hey 42 here the world's main exporter of
Brazil nuts is not Brazil it's Bolivia
welcome to RIF Vikings who died in bed
rather than battle went to a special
afterlife where it was always foggy the
difference between hardwood and softwood
has to do with its seeds and has nothing
at all to do with how hard or soft the
wood actually is almost 1/3 of the
world's languages are spoken only in
Africa air pollution kills 4000 Chinese
people per day jirafa
already extinct in at least seven
countries in Africa a recent study found
that sitting straight or at ninety
degrees is bad for your back
you should slouch at an angle of 135
degrees to provide maximum support for
your spa cremation causes silicone
breast implants to explode according to
Switzerland law social animals like
guinea pigs must live with a body owning
only what is considered animal abuse and
is illegal Canada has the longest
coastline of any country in the world
the original recipe for chocolate
contained chili powder instead of sugar
shark pregnancies last for up to four
years even though the West is accustomed
to apples oranges and bananas the most
commonly eaten fruit around the world is
actually mangoes Hospital a village in
Ireland doesn't have a hospital
the CIA operation to invade Cuba and
take down Castro was called Operation
castration thanks for the view subscribe
for more thoughty2